senator Martha McSally was America's
first female fighter pilot to fly in
combat and she rose to the ranks to
become an Air Force colonel the Arizona
Republican was appointed to the US
Senate back in 2018 taking over for the
late John McCain she faces a tough
reelection this fall however in a new
book dare to fly simple lessons in never
giving up
McSally writes about fighting adversity
and sexism throughout her career and she
joins us now from Tucson Arizona Senator
Max Ally good morning and welcome
there's so much to get to in the book
many wonderful bits of wisdom hard-won
over the course of your life and career
but I want to get a couple questions in
on Washington the Senate is talking
about possibly picking up another
stimulus bill we've got tens of millions
of Americans out of work possibly 20%
unemployment what would you like to see
in that bill well back in Arizona we
have so many people who are safely going
back to work but there's still so many
more who are unemployed in my
neighborhood all over our community
small businesses got access to PPP but I
have legislation legislation that allows
them to have forgiveable of cost for PPE
and other things so I think the next
package needs to focus very much on the
American worker family and small
business and getting things back on
track while we still fight to defeat
this virus which we will what would that
look like in supporting the American
worker in your view for example would
you be behind hazard pay for frontline
workers well we're in the middle of
conversations about this and I'm
listening to my constituents every
single day so when I deploy back to DC
to the new combat zone I'm in I'm gonna
bring Arizona stories Arizona's needs
and we'll be in those negotiations going
forward it's interesting you call our
Washington a combat zone you you write
in the book that working in Washington
is the most frustrating thing you've
ever done in your life and you've done a
lot of frustrating things so let's talk
about politics for a second there's a
bit of a Democratic surge it would seem
in Arizona you're trailing your opponent
in in your Senate race Joe Biden seems
to be doing well against President Trump
there according to polls is there a
democratic surge in Arizona and if so
what's behind it well I look
like this could be the last year of my
life I learned that when I lost my dad
at the age of 12 I talked about that in
there to fly and so I'm doing everything
I can in this unprecedented time to help
Arizonans in order to get the relief
that they need to get through this
there's a big fight ahead and there's
gonna be an important choice I would say
in my race the question of who is going
to take on China is going to be very
significant I have never trusted a
communist in my life my opponent
actually has been invested by the
Chinese Communist Party and and
companies and he's invested in them I'm
gonna take them on and confront them and
I think going forward the voters will
hear more about their choice in front of
them all right well as you say it could
be the last year of your life is the way
you live it and politically speaking
that may be true let's get into the book
a little bit you you've you've made it
through so much in your life that you
say you have something called a misery
database that you draw on to get through
adversity what is a misery database
well I shared this story in dare to fly
when I was climbing Mount Kilimanjaro
with some friends and one of her brought
his son and he was an elite athlete he
was really struggling and I just shared
that the rest of us we've been through a
lot of difficult times and to put one
foot in front of the other we were
tapping into that misery database to
give us strength to get through this
challenge and his database was empty but
he was building it at that moment and if
he could just get to the top of the
mountain it could propel him to do
amazing things in his life and he made
it and he's moved on to do incredible
things and I think for all of us we can
either reach back to our tough times and
we can have it pull us down and hold us
back or we can tap in and it can give us
resolve and strength and I talked about
that in my book all right senator
mcsalley
thank you very much I do want to
underscore one other point you make in
the book and that you attach to the
corona virus and this national response
we're all going through right now and
that is the lesson that you've learned
to do things afraid don't wait for
perfect conditions don't wait for the
perfect answer don't wait for the
perfect moment that moment is now good
words to live by and Senator Max I'll be
in here today
exactly of the a time
dare to fly us and share their stories
with me - no it really is a wonderful
book people who are interested in
politics people who are interested in
aviation the military there's something
for everyone dare to fly is available in
bookstores today